Posséder une arme en France, c'est condamnable à un maximum de 6 ans de prison.
Tuer quelqu'un en lui poussant une chaise dessus condamnable à 18.
Ne pas mettre un pouce vert sur une vidéo de Squeezie est condamnable à plus de 10 ans de prison. Pew.
Pas propre. Yo tout le monde, c'est Squeezie ! Aujourd'hui, on se retrouve sur un jeu sur lequel on va devoir deviner laquelle des deux infractions proposées engendre une peine d'au moins x années.
Et aujourd'hui est un grand jour, puisque j'a bien expliqué le but du jeu.
Putain, je propose qu'on s'applaudisse- non.
Par exemple, là, on a "Le traffic sexuel des enfants de moins de 14 ans."
Alors là, je pense que tu prends une bonne grosse peine dans la gueule.
Et en face, on a la "Possession d'une arme à feu ou de munitions par un fugitif ou toxicomane qui a 3 condamnations pour crimes violents ou pour infraction à latifs aux drogues."
What (Quoi) ?
Y a pas plus précis. Moi, écoutez, je suis juge, je sais, je suis inspecteur, je suis beaucoup de choses, je suis un fils de pute aussi.
Mais avant tout, un juge, et je pense que faire du trafic sess-xu-xuel. J'arrive même pas à parler tellement que ça me fait quelque chose, c'est horrible. Sous des enfants de moins de 14 ans, tu te prends perpet'.
Donc, la peine la plus petite est logiquement la "Possession d'arme à feu." Je pense. Ah ben, c'est pareil, 15 ans dans les deux cas. Atteeennnnnds... La vie est injuste.
Voilà, c'est tout pour moi, abonnez-vous. 2eme question. "Le traffic sexuel d'enfants-", mais qu'est-ce que vous avez avec les traffics sexuels, là ? 'Tain, je commence à me poser des questions sur les gens qui ont créer ce jeu, bordel.
"Le traffic sexuel d'enfants, ayant plus de 14 ans, mais moins de 18 ans, par la force et la foudre."
En même temps, si ils ont plus de 18 ans, ça s'appelle, des adultes, c'est plus des enfants.
OK, OK, j'arrête. Et en face, nous avons "Causer ou conspirer pour causer des dommages ou la destruction d'un véhicule à moteur transportant des déchets radioactifs de haute activité ou des combustibles nucléaires usés avec l'intention de mettre en danger la sécurité." (Tousse)
Plus longue la phrase ! Attends, putain, un juge, il doit avoir une respiration, mon gars.
Écoutez, faites confiance au juge Squeezie, tu prends forcément plus dans la gueule en voulant faire du traffic sexuel qu'en voulant péter un véhicule qui transporte des déchets radioactifs.
30 ans ! Tu prends 30 ans ! En pétant une voiture qui transporte des trucs radioactifs !
Et tu prends 10 ans ! Seulement pour faire du traffic SEXUEL ! C'est injuste, abonnez-vous.
Alors, dans mon raisonnement, j'ai eu faux, mais j'ai quand même eu bon parce qu'en fait, j'avais pas vu, mais fallait, fallait cliquer sur "Sell" où tu te prends une peine d'au moins 30 ans.
Ce qu'on a fait ! Juge Squeezie, il est fort, mais des fois, il fait pas exprès !
"Endommager ou tenter, d'endommager une propriété des U.S. avec du feu ou des explosifs, SI mort s'en suit."
Face à "Engager une conduite explicite avec un enfant dans le but de produire toute représentation visuelle d'un tel comportement : si mort s'en suit."
Ah, j'ai pas tout compris à cette deuxième. Dans quel cas tu te prends 30 ans ? Je dirai le premier, mon gars.
AH NON, MÊME PAS ! Ok, ok, bon, on a gagné 2 procès sur 3.
Ça va ! Dans quel cas tu te prends une peine d'au moins 30 ans ?
"Pour la falsification d'un saut de notaire" Ouais.
Pff ! La réponse claquée du juge claqué.
Ou "La vente d'un enfant par des parents ou un tuteur légal aux faims d'exploitation sexuelles." Ben mec ! Mec, allez, sans hésiter, la deuxième.
Voilà, ben oui ! Ben oui, tu prends- Ah, tu prends qu'un an que de falsifier un saut de notaire. J'aurait dit un peu plus, quand même.
Allez, on va mettre une peine de mort pour ça.
Mais non, la peine de mort, c'est terrible, Squee-
TU FERMES TA GUEULE, C'EST QUI LE JUGE ?
C'est-
C'est qui le juge ?!
C'est- C'est qui le juge ?!
C'est- Voilà !
Alors, laquelle de ces infractions engendre un emprisonnement d'au minimum 5 ans. Celle de gauche, j'ai pas besoin de lire.
"La production/possession/réception/transport d'une représentation visuelle obscène de l'abus sexuel d'enfants."
Arrêtez avec les enfants, laissez-les en paix !
"La fabrication, distribution, ou possession avec l'intention de distribuer - de tout l'annexe 1 ou 2 des médicaments - de drogues synthétiques."
Elle, elle prend plus de 50, je dirais, je- Ah, je sais pas là. Attends, jeu Squeezie en PLS.(?)
Je pense que tu prends au moins 5 ans pour le, le, les trucs, euh, des enfants. Hugo, tu prends plus. (?)
Oh là là là là ! Putain, mais faites-vous juger par Squeezie, quoi ! La justice, on la connais bien, nous !
Alors, laquelle de ces deux infractions prend un minimum de 10 ans ?
"L'exercice de la pharmacie et la vente de poisons en Chine." Pff, what the fuck ?
"Importation ou exportation illègale, pas de morts ou de blessures graves."
QUOI ? Tu prends que un mois pour vendre des poisons en Chine ?
C'est abusé, mec !
C'est pour ça que j'aime bien les jeux comme ça, c'est des fois, t'es étonné, des fois, ça tétonne de ouf, les phrases...
Arrêtez, vous connaissez déjà.
Ok, ok ! Tout le monde se calme ! Question suivante.
Laquelle de ces deux infractions engendre un emprisonnement d'au moins 25 ans !
"La trahison." Ah, ça, je sais que c'est puni véner !
"La violation des interdictions relatives a des armes atomiques, aucun décès résultat."
Tu te prends 25 ans pour les deux.
Pour trahison, en tout cas, c'est sûr.
5 ans pour trahison et 25 ans pour, euh... Que 5 ans, les traîtres ?
Ah, qu'en faire ? Je pensais que la trahison, c'était violent, quoi !
Attends, moi, je me crois dans une dictature, c'est affreux.
Laquelle de ces deux infractions engendre une peine d'au minimum 5 ans ?
"Connaître le transport intérétatique, l'expédition, la vente ou la possession avec l'intention de vendre des représentations visuelles d'un mineur subissant un comportement sexuellement explicite."
OK.
(Rire) La 2ème ! "Héberger certains étrangers avec l'intention ou avec des raisons de croire que l'étranger peut commettre un crime illégal."
Jawad ! Jawad, c'est pour toi !
(Jawad) On m'a, on m'a demandé de rendre service, j'ai rendu service monsieur.
(Squeezie) Alors, est-ce qu'à votre avis Jawad a pris une peine d'au moins 5 ans ?
Ben non !
Alors, le 1er, c'est "Avoir connaissance"
Du coup, je pense que c'est juste la 1ère.
Voilà !
Et Jawad, il risquait jusqu'à 3 ans de prison !
La prochaine fois, Jawad, tu réfléchiras à 2 fois avant d'héberger des gens, hein ?
Laquelle de ces infractions engendre une peine d'au minimum de 5 ans ?
"L'intrusion sur des terres fédérales pour la chasse ou le tir."
"Tuer toute personne engagée dans ou à cause de la performance de ses fonctions officielles en tant qu'inspecteur de volaille ou de produit de volaille." ?
Wha-at ??
Il y a une peine précise si tu butes un inspecteur de volaille, c'est quand même très bizarre.
Du coup, qui prends 5 ans ?
Moi, je pense que c'est pour aller chasser ou tirer sur des terres fédérales, je pense.
5 jours ? Ah, c'est nul ! Par contre, tu prends la MORT ou l'emprisonnement à vie, ben oui, tu as tué quelqu'un, putain, je suis débile, mais quel juge je suis, putain.
Aaaaahhhhh....
Quelle infraction entraîne un minimum de 30 ans ?
"La soustraction, la fraude ou de fausses entrées par ton agent bancaire."
Ou "L' achat d'un enfant aux faims d'exploitation sexuelles."
Arrê- putain, j'en ai marre. Non mais là, ça-. Titoi, Timothée, Matthieu, David, je, je suis désolé.
Je pense que quand t'achètes un enfant, pour faire des choses sexuelles avec, euh, tu risques tout de suite la peine de mort, et même si t'as pas la peine de mort, le père de cet enfant t'infligera la peine de mort.
2 ans. Quand il y a fraude et tout.
Et tu prends 30 ans, tu te prends pas une bonne peine de- En fait, ça dépend le pays, aussi, moi, je suis pas un juge aux U.S., je suis pas un juge dans les étoles où il y a la peine de mort.
Je suis un juge en France !
Alors, laquelle de ces infractions engendre une peine d'un mois ? Oh ?
"Refuser de témoigner devant le Congrès." Ouais...
Ou "Kidnapper un mineur." (Rire)
Tu prends que 1 mois quand tu kidnappes un mineur ?
Non. Tu prends plus, je pense.
Voilà. Oui, voilà, tu prends 20 ans quand tu kidnappes. Je me disais, euh...
Juge Squeezie en action !
"Marchandage de la fixation des prix." ou alors "Pour la prise d'otage entraînée par la mort de quelqu'un." (Rire)
Voilà, tu prends la mort ou la prison à vie.
"Organiser ou gérer une entreprise qui encaisse 5 millions tout les 24 mois." ou alors "Tuer-" (Rire) "Tuer le cheval d'un policier."
Wha ! Tu prends la prison à vie ou l'emprisonnement à vie quand tu tues le cheval d'un policier, putain... C'est ouf !
Messieurs dames, c'est la fin du 1er trimestre, maintenant, notre relevé des notes.
Quelle est notre moyenne générale ?
14/20. Ça défonce, ça défonce !
Attendez, je vous donne ma carte, comme ça, si vous avez un procès, vous pouvez m'appeller pour vous juger.
Ma carte ! (Rire) Une carte de visite ! Ça, c'est une carte SD !
Tu ris, putain ! Tu ris, là ! Tu ris ! Turi.
Le joueur de basket.
Oh là là là là là !!!
Là, je vais te dire, là, on va prendre une peine de 10 ans pour 2 blagues nulles d'affilée !
Voilà les gens, c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur je sais même pas, je sais toujours pas le nom de ce jeu, mais il y a le lien dans le description, si vous voulez tester, c'est gratuit, c'est hyper sympa !
En fait, j'avais un jeu comme ça sauf que le jeu disait, tu apprends pas mal de trucs, et surtout, tout ce qui est chez condamnations, pour des peines, il y a des trucs très précis et très bizarres, dans la Loi qui sont marqués.
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu, on se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine. Ciao tout le monde, PEACE !
*Musique d'outro*